hello and welcome to our real thoughts
I'm Bridge to Terabithia how film that
everyone said don't do and that was
about to break a million sunny day today
I was alone when that happen that's my
smoke dick part of me um awful I I can't
oh but uh you know little girls dying it
just equals great comedy um Leslie died
for your sins I do the one at the last
con I went to the one thing I guess this
one group of people is just really
quoting the scene where it's like the
life shiz that she closes the purse I
was just part of it just led to so many
good jokes um but okay so we should get
to a real thoughts on it um I can't say
I hate this movie honestly um it's bad
enough to hate it's one of those where
if you can clearly see what they're
trying to do and I like movies that
succeed in doing this uh where it's not
like you know it's it's kind of like
doing something like the Sandlot
but then throwing in like something
that's really tragic you know it does
happen at either is out of the blue and
that happens in life I mean particularly
dad that just kind of happens out of
nowhere and how his deals with it was
based on a net I mean that base base on
an actual event but it was been the
author I believe had lost a friend and
it was sudden hmm so wait and you write
you read the book and you said the book
was it okay big shock but even darker
than the movie it was the book just for
me we didn't read that book in the
fourth grade and that was like that was
the literary equivalent of Bambi's mom
because you know you're just reading and
it's just like your friend Leslie is
dead like there was just this I remember
as a child my jaw just dropped and like
what no that can't happen
I can't wait there's something wrong is
somebody printed this wrong that that
can't happen like it just was really
dark and shocking like it really and I
just remember as a kid that was kind of
in a funk all day like I just and I
remembered I was young enough that I
didn't quite understand the concept
because I was a good swimmer
even as a kid I couldn't understand the
concept of drowning in such a small
amount of water didn't they say like she
knocked herself out with her saw eight
it broke and she hit like I am okay I
haven't read this book literally since
well like I was in the third or fourth
grade or something in the fourth grade I
thought she hit her head but that she
had drowned in the the creek that was
the crossing there like it was face down
yeah like face down and she drowned I
maybe I got that wrong I mean she
slipped and definitely hit her head or
something it was from the road Bayless
death and I just remember not
comprehending them I'm like but how can
you drown it was just like I remember
afterwards just I was in a funk like wow
well if that could happen that I could
die any second
like it was when I water every day it
can fucking kill you first moment where
I realized even as a child my own sense
of mortality and I'm like oh my god I
could die like like I could get struck
by lightning I could kids can die it was
it was actually kind of traumatic for me
like as a kid like reading the book I
was like fuck so that night I just see
you like reading it is I'll just look at
that part fuck like just loud until the
classroom or whatever
well I we were eighties kids so we
definitely swore hey so I think that was
everybody's collective thought bubble
when they got cuz we're reading it in
class out loud and there was almost as
collective shock like everybody there
you're reading it out loud
yeah hold you shit yeah everybody
attacks me and everybody every student
had to take turns reading unfortunately
I didn't have that part cuz maybe I
would have been like your friend
Leslie's dead fuck like but I remember
there was this like collective sort of
and you know and I I'm not complaining I
think kids need Darkness either this
goes back to the dawn blue thing but it
it was like everybody in class I
remember that day was kind of like whoa
and then the blocking in a day yeah a
few people who like read the book like a
little bit ahead the really smart kids
are like yeah I knew that for a couple
days and wasn't quite right and then
like and then it was really great for
the people that missed it because they
weren't in class then they showed up the
next day so I don't know what I've
enrolled yeah
oh that's Metz it exactly so yeah it the
book and this is the problem with the
movie there's too many different groups
pulling in too many separate directions
it I believe that the screenwriter was
the son of the author I think she gave
her blessing I think she did a yeah
don't call it a swamp yeah don't don't
quote me on that but um so you can see
him trying but he's also writing a
Disney movie and then aunt is out back
playing with the Disney movie guy boys a
Disney movie like well and let's be
honest I think this is bag like pre
wreckit-ralph pre frozen pre gravity
fall pre cool Disney now why Disney
actually is really taking a huge steps
now to being actually pretty awesome
again uh and maybe this is part of the
sloppy transition I don't know cuz for
Disney it it's kind of a risk you know
but if you if ya the book there is a not
only just a darkness to it and heavy
adult themes um but there's a grittiness
and it was the grittiness to me that
rang the most false in the movie
everything about that school about the
kids about the bully about leslie about
the boy just rang false like every
single thing because it was a disney
school where they're bullies but nothing
really bad happens it's a disney school
where kids get into trouble but not real
trouble like smoking or anything like it
I just remember at least if I'm
remembering the book right there just
felt like the kids there was a realistic
quality to them that there was kind of
this 70s sort of like early 80s I've
just kind of grittiness to it like
reading the book like when they would do
things like you know you would hear
things like about smoking and stuff in
there and like the kids felt real um you
know maybe I'm misremembering that
because that was so many years ago but I
thought I remember cuz I remember a lot
of books
seem to have that quality when I was
reading it I was like wow I like some of
the things that kids are doing like you
know and I didn't get that in the the
Disney film at all it just felt my guys
safe like they all no doubt if I ever
said of That's So Raven or some Disney
Channel they were definitely the
elements were still there cuz they still
address the the bully that was I think
beaten by her father I guess um you know
or the father was Stern's there but it
was you know down it was like fraud no
yeah yeah no and then um and then
there's dialogue that I'm like bonk how
shocked this made it in Disney film but
it's obviously like you said can't
justify like you know the little girl
saying you know goddamn Z and a hell
goddamn see the hell now I can see that
like kind of in a gritty realistic kid
phone cuz that is how kids would talk
you know sort of not quite comprehending
or maybe comprehending - well what their
parents are teaching whatever about
religion and you know can we hear these
talks like you know when you're a little
kid somebody like me you know no I got
the right way and here's how it is it
can be about anything to be much more
than be about religion can be about TV
shows and can be about serious stuff or
non serious stuff because kids don't
quite know the difference yet uh so
that's the other thing I think the
religious element was definitely toned
down I love there was way more in the
book if I remember it mmm wait cuz she
was like it's only touched he's only
even hinted upon like but I thought I
swear remember there's way more of like
this religious element of like the
atheism and stuff yeah hell and stuff
yeah like I get it it's in there but
you're right it's very very tone there
buddy it's very it's it's just it's it's
light it's like a low-calorie soft drink
or something it's the diet coke of
here's a religious discussion in a kids
book like and I think if it's done right
I mean I think people again this is why
I don't know if I can like blame the
writer or the director necessarily for
this because I avoided his Disney film
again I think it was the studio yeah and
it's one of those things where it's like
that stuff the stuff they're talking
about in the emotions that kids feel
when talking about this stuff is really
heavy uncomfortable stuff uh and if
you're really gonna talk about it and
you're
can address it you have to kind of
really dive into it instead of sort of
touching about it than having your
popularly dressed Lesley character who
was you know I think in the book hipster
girl that drops yeah in the book she's
described as a tomboy which is like
that's okay so she's not wearing pretty
dresses but it's like that's definitely
not a tomboy
you know that's those are pretty
fashionable colorful she's well you know
picked out outfits you know I mean you
can see like you know like I said I
think I compared like a Barbie doll you
know in the show and so you can see like
hipster Barbie like yeah that's it color
oriented um and you know a lot of people
were listen I least from again what I
remember him the book I didn't think she
was quite hot enough I still was kind of
like she could almost be the popular
just sort of quirky girl in school hmm
like all the like I could I could see
that and I'm like I'm not sure that's
what they should have come but again she
looks like a construction out of some
disney playbook like it I can't I'm not
sure if that's really on the
writer/director even costume designer do
I just feel like Disney's just like yeah
make her look like this like well and
the actor was like a Disney Channel star
if the actress a lot of people serve you
know what we're saying comments and
stuff like that while you're making fun
of that she's too pretty now what pretty
people can you know act this way or
whatever uh I think for the character
they are trying to go for it it sounds
like you know she was supposed to be
kind of light like she can be pretty but
still kind of average a little quirky
and weird and stuff like that and this
girl again that she's a kid I mean can
default in too much it's another girl
spoke way too clearly was way too
precise I mean everything seemed like
you're at you're out of a movie you're
not a real kid you are a movie construct
and that's not one of us film Mia Danny
had a kid that really felt real if a boy
felt very real to me that that is the
one character I'm like no he was very
gently de was great yeah he really was I
thought yeah he did all his stuff fine
and she I can't tell if it's on her like
her acting isn't great or as a director
problem um I I always tend to just go
with the director cuz I'm just like
then you could have talked to casting or
somebody like you know but yeah he was
really good she just she felt really
false and I'm not saying that's her
problem
as an actress I'm saying something about
the way that character was put together
in that scenario just came off is so
whimsical and it felt I felt like the
characters a book felt yeah the
character in the book felt real whereas
her character in the movie felt like
some sort of construct like oh she's
supposed to be the one the the Pippi
Longstocking type to turn their world
upside down and know what they're
painting on the walls that was painful
Oh God remember that paint job they're
all about parents were yeah oh it's like
yeah so you should be a driver yeah and
like yeah I have the perfect fucking
saying for everything and the thing is
when you read the book aspects of that
are there but they're developed and it
feels like okay this is real and there
is just sort of a culture clash here
you know in the middle of this backwoods
sort of town but like in the movie it's
so glossed over like they felt like no
child would have the patience to sit
through that that it just they sort of
breeze through it and so you get these
caricature parents who are singing into
the paintbrush and it's like every bad
cliche scene from a chick flick you see
like play the pop song sing painting
home laughing baiting on each other
see now what I always got you know like
at least what they were probably trying
to do was that he's seeing her parents
and becoming jealous because his parents
weren't like that but again it's because
they're trying so hard to make them to
perfect they there isn't there's hell
Envy there's doubting reality there's an
aspect of that in the book because in
the book he had real issues I think with
his father and I remember just kind of
in the film just being very confused
because at the end it comes down to
Robert Patrick and then I always forget
that actors ain't Peeta you know they're
and it's a great scene at the end but
I'm like this didn't feel earned like
this felt like there was some scenes
missing that played up the problems they
had
even more and the problems got really
dumbed down kind of in the movie the
missing key and the you know but in the
book there was way more the father was a
more complex character the issues they
had seem more complex and the movie just
sort of just well let's dumb it down to
you know something simple just to make
the father kind of the bad guy until the
end when all of a sudden you know it's
like oh now we're fine I think what you
know what what I think of with this film
is that the story sounds to me you know
like what it was trying to convey and
sounds like very much did uh and some of
this is left up to the reader's
imagination but it created this very
real environment and this very world the
same way that To Kill a Mockingbird it
just felt so real it felt like malicious
time capsule from that period in time
and I don't member the exact date it was
supposed to be like I always got this
impression when I was reading it it was
years back from when I was reading it as
a kid so maybe the 70s or some fun like
but it sounds like it also captured the
emotions of childhood it just can't your
child really well and childhood you know
and as bright and colorful and wonderful
as you can be so dark and scary but yes
I mean it it can be a very dark disturb
and very fearful play and gritty we
forget that I watch something as simple
as a Christmas story and when Ralphie
swears son of a bitch yeah your father's
a horse's ass and this is that I'm like
why don't kids swear in kids movies it
seems so unrealistic to me well another
thing like I was so afraid of like illa
fragile little minds like I'm not saying
kids need to be dropping f-bombs left
and right in movies but know that the
really awkward when they do try to have
the kids where and it doesn't work and
it's like oh wow you're trying to go for
the gritty but they're clearly not like
these are not kids you swear but uh but
what I was saying is that because then
if you're gonna try and bring this
reality which is really what the book
was writing about was writing about this
reality the reality of emotion and
reality of childhood and the place you
live and stuff like that uh you have to
just go full force and you can't sort of
tap upon it you you need to go all the
way and I think you need like kind of
the best of the best you need the best
actor
you need the best writers and you need
to fight as hard as you can against a
studio that's trying to do something
else which again I'm not saying like you
know are you director come on just fight
back it's like I'm not saying that I
mean it's it's really the biggest issue
is this needed to not be a Disney movie
this needed to be picked up by Miramax
or and I hate to say it like some Oscar
bait studio look into you know grabs it
but it needed that ability to get out of
that Disney box and make it darker make
it grittier make it slower keep it smart
keep it intelligent and you couldn't do
that because you know you had to frame
the mouse yeah you know it is to kiss
did cuz we always say Disney can get
dark with like they're villains on there
uh you know darker themes and stuff but
it's like here's what I think there's a
difference between dark and
uncomfortable and I think this film
needed to go to uncomfortable in order
for it to work um and I don't think a
Disney Disney is never willing to go to
uncomfortable they'll go to dark I don't
think they'll quite go to uncomfortable
few exceptions hunched back at times got
a little uncomfortable in a good way
but even then just the slightest touch I
mean but yeah there's very few times
Disney will do that and I don't see
happening in the future so it's one of
those things where it might just be like
you know just the predicament you're
stuck with Disney you have to make the
compromises you know Farrah that's why
if it's moving I was going to work
that's why I don't hate the movie
because I can see decent people actors
directors writers trying to make the
best out of something that they've been
kind of just shoved into like make a
Disney movie and you can see them trying
and you know that's the case because the
only parts of the movie that are almost
flawless in their execution is after she
died ya know that part of it is the only
part that felt like the book and I'm
like cuz this is dark disturbing uh you
know kind of messed up angry angry yeah
I'm like it's almost like the direct
it's almost like I could see the
director just like doing it for that
portion of the movies like whatever I
just want to get to this part this is
where the need of the story is
it no it really feels like yeah like
this director had a very clear vision of
what that you know last third should
look like it feel like and then was
putting all the focus on that and then
everything else is like well it doesn't
matter it just has to be happy and you
know whatever Disney can handle our
happiness I can love make the changes
whatever and I just have to get this
right but it's it really is a two-way
street it's like both have to be very
well don't have to balance and this may
have been the trade-off because the
story I read somewhere is that Disney
initially wanted them to change the
ending so she lives yeah that would have
fans well um and the writer the
screenwriter they put her in a coma or
yeah I'm in a coma
let there be some hope let her wake up
and maybe at the end or you know who
knows maybe possibly for a sequel while
you were sleeping
uh you know and the to is credit the
writer was just like I like you assholes
get this at all like this is like no
we're not gonna that's not what the
story is about that is a complete
betrayal of like that's like doing Star
Trek too and then at the very end spawns
like oh sorry just a mistake now I'm
fine I'm good like you know at least
they went through the whole other movie
to bring him back like it you can't do
that so they were worried those like
what's too dark because kids are not
gonna like you know I'm late
ridiculous but so I'm wondering if that
was the trade-off that like they're like
okay we'll keep our dark ending and
everything but then we got a leg spruce
up the first half of the movie and make
it more fun and goofy and like um and
remove all of the grittiness from it
which really I think is what bugs me the
most just cuz I still wouldn't say all
there's still like I said they you know
I feels like it feels like they
mentioned the gritty but they don't
experience it they mention it they say
it but they don't go through it they
don't feel it you know it's in passing
oh her parents you know are getting a
divorce or he got arrested or something
like that oh you know God does exist or
she didn't believe or whatever all this
person is going through some sort of
terrible abusers that you know they say
it but they don't feel it they don't
experience it if you
really trying to do something
realistically and talk about themes like
death and really resonate with a child I
don't understand why you wouldn't make
that school experience realistic that's
what bothers me
oh I agree I the only thing I can
imagine is that they were trying so hard
to as adults create this very
romanticized version of childhood that
is then destroyed by the reality that
you know kids can die and stuff can
happen but I still don't think that
works because if you're gonna feel safe
or that person you have to always be in
that reality this is the other problem
fantasy world is escaping that reality
so the reality needs to be as realistic
as possible yeah and exactly in this yes
the phantom world no and I think I think
this is the other problem I think one of
the bigger problems the book head is
updating it I think they should have
gone the sandlot route the Christmas
story route and set it whenever the
frickin book was written like I think my
updating it so it looks like 2005 for
whatever was made just in the country
somewhere was a huge mistake I think
they may have been able to get away with
more and at least maybe you could have
had a kid be convinced it may be because
this is an older time period maybe kids
actually acted like this you know a
little more sanitized we know different
cuz we grew up like but but by making it
in 2005 and for and everything it it
just rang so false I'm like what kids
talk like this what this is how Disney
Channel kids talk without kids in a real
high school in 2005 talk yeah maybe I'll
say she seems like something the was a
girl see myself out at the Disney
Channel she didn't seem like that's what
I said from the beginning yeah she's
used a disney channel and that i think
is a huge mistake I think maybe had you
set it back in time you could argue that
it's a tie it's a period piece where you
just remove some of the gritty elements
so you kid could get a little bit of
distance there you know it may be buy it
a little more I don't know but I
remember sitting there halfway through
the film and thinking that I'm just like
I just can't see any high school like
sounding like this like it just it this
is just too dis new fight and for a book
that was you know dark and really a
acting I think not just for me but for a
lot of people had to read it I still
know people that when you mention bridge
to terabithia like oh my god
fucking I slit my wrists you know it
really needed to resonate and feel real
and it just didn't feel real except for
like the funeral and when she dies and
that small section of the movie and some
of the stuff like I think there were
editions they had the bully being the
troll I don't remember if that was the
case in the book I'm wondering if that
was agitation I thought that was it I
thought that was a great touch um but
more of the fantasy like the elements of
reality go into fantasy which is like
okay the bully's making the BP beep
sound and that's what the monsters make
no fucking shit all that's incorporated
the reality no that's taking something
you heard throwing it in there making
the tiniest bit of a connect a very
obvious connection but I mean like the
troll being the bully I mean that the
resolution the ending of the film I
thought they were like monsters which is
yelling the father but I thought that
was actually pretty yeah I thought that
was pretty brilliant they strike me as
things that you know the son of the
author would have come up with as a way
to expand upon you know so I mean there
were good ideas there it's just once
again I just think the mouse must be
obeyed you want a much better version of
this idea people how would you do it
right I wouldn't say necessary this is
doing it right but it's definitely
closer and more creative like where the
wild things are why are the wild things
are the emotions and there are 100%
genuine if you want like a concept of
what I'm talking about like as much as I
hate to say it Monster Squad the way
those kids acted was how we really acted
in the early yeah well that's just kind
of general like and I I think you can do
say a lot I think it's over I think you
can do that I don't think you can with a
Disney film I think they've got too much
of an image to protect which is why I
think Disney should not they should have
let it go or sentient does Mir make
something Disney now yeah yeah we're
sent it to the attention to Miramax and
say you know technically we own it will
make money of it but this is not this is
not Disney it's beer backs you know yeah
it's I think you're right I think they
should have handed it off to
you know one video we like I think we
liked the movie overall better than we
let on but we all were less yeah exactly
don't hate it
I was probably one of the better films
we've watched for the NC like it would
be my top 20 of okay this was actually
this tolerable yeah yeah like you know
the it when I do my was watching the
film because it was getting actually
pretty good reviews and but they were
also Mark V it's like the next Narnia
which that's a whole other said the
marketing was all lately
oh no completely wrong we can literally
great could you saw the trailers you're
like hey this is like what the book is
this is not oh no cuz you need something
really weirds read the book yeah he
hadn't read the book and so when this
came out years ago
I'm like watching the television I just
burst out laughing and and you're like
what's so funny I'm like I can't believe
they're marketing this as some cute
fantasy and you were just like what it's
not I'm like no no no no I'm like this
is like marketing Schindler's List as a
romantic cavity I mean I'm like I and
that was the one part of it that did
make me laugh because I was like the
thought of all these little children
going in thinking they're gonna get this
cute little fantasy and then hitting
that point you know your friend Leslie's
dead like crying in the theater and this
is like oh man I wish I could have seen
that one because he was getting the
reviews and like you know and people say
oh wait the credit roll yeah it's really
good stuff and I'm watching this movie
the first 10 minutes I was watching with
my wife I said do you like this you know
she's very open to like you know the
more happy go like it so she goes no
this is really stupid
and we're watching it and I say okay
somebody has to die cuz there's no way
this would get critical praise if
somebody doesn't die at first I was
thinking the sister and that so as I saw
the girl so we had cost across the rug
DC this logo with a smile I'm like she's
gone yeah she is dead and that's kind of
the biggest crime well image you're not
supposed to see that yeah and that's the
other problem is in the book you don't
see a guy I I don't think any of us
reading it just saw that coming I mean
it literally was just out of nowhere
that's why it was so scary like that's
why I was like I could die at any second
I think the world's out to kill me so
yeah the fact that they would like hint
that and like
play up you know her angelic qualities
that she's swinging across just big
mistake but yeah I told to market that
film as some happy-go-lucky fantasy I
was like that is the most brilliantly
evil marketing I've ever seen in my life
well and that's why the reasons I really
wanted to do the review too cuz whenever
I told people I didn't like the movie
they're always like oh cuz of the
marketing right you just didn't like it
cuz the marketing I'm like no that did
help but it's like there's a lot of
reasons I don't like this film and
everyone always insist so it's cuz you
thought you're gonna get a fantasy so
I'm like okay alright I can show you I
did the review with that incredibly
mean-spirited title card that might be
like the meanest I've ever done that was
pretty great so um but yeah it's uh and
why would you hit it I think the reason
it got the critical reception it did is
cuz it ended on a high note and by that
I mean her death yeah I think that part
of the film was done well enough that
the critics just sort of overlooked got
amnesia but that yeah if you end the
movie well it up you can sometimes
forget about the first half because I
think if the whole thing was like the
first half of that movie I don't think
we've gotten the critical praise yeah I
think to that for the same reason we
don't like it as much
I think critics did I think some critics
look they was like well this is a Disney
movie so if I lower the bar this
actually isn't that bad I think that may
have given it a boost like whereas we're
just like well this is actually a dark
and gritty story but it's a Disney movie
um but yeah I don't hate it I don't
think it's very good but I don't hate it
I do
I appreciate what they were trying to do
and I like how succeeds in the last
three and likes I think the boy is very
good uh you know and actually I am I
really like it when young child actors
like ones are legitimately like hey you
get real talent go on to something
really great I am glad he's in The
Hunger Games and he's doing great shows
I didn't even realize until I was
watching the UH that review again Bridge
to Terabithia I was showing it to
somebody and then I'm just like wait
wait is it PETA I totally forgot this
well I think I make a cake joke or
something like cake decorating cake joke
or something like that um but yeah I
like it when really good shot actors
like
get rewarded for legitimately good
acting um I'm not going crazy it's
always nice to UM so make it dark make a
gritty handedly surreal
yeah make it real hand it to someone
other than the mouse you know and it may
have been good but I think it was just
too many not even that there were too
many cooks in the kitchen it was just
each cook had a different idea of what
they wanted to do
I think the writer the director and the
studio each had three different concepts
I think the writer in the director of
lone could have made it work I think
when you add the studio executives in it
going well according to the chart she
should just be in a coma you know can we
cut back on this and swearing and move
it you know it I think we're gonna do
I'd be curious if Disney would do this
well now like I said because now that
they have done so much this is what much
kind of different stuff what okay what
what under the Disney label Walt Disney
Pictures not Miramax's I mean what have
they done they were even close to this
while talking more about like the themes
of what they've been doing like wreck-it
Ralph I mean the the moral of wreck-it
Ralph is deal all the really good still
get away with it because they're
operating in a video game can deal and
there's very candy every no no but
that's why I'm saying like I'm wondering
if watch the prom a bridge to terabithia
there's the fantasy element but
otherwise it's it's not pretty
okay III would omit if they didn't now
if I had to guess if they didn't now I
would say that the fantasy world would
be played up more but then that would
balance out so they could get more dark
and gritty in the realistic world so
they would up the playful stuff but it'd
be only to offset the really harsh stuff
if I even guess um which I guess I mean
it's not like it's years and years ago I
mean it's what not even like you know a
decade ago and maybe did a decade ago
though I think about it it's worth what
2015 knows 2005 yeah sound like that so
as amazing as a decade but frickin oh um
but uh yes it that'd be my fantasy of
speculation who knows um so yeah that's
our real thoughts on it and we will get
back to you with more of a real thoughts
and hey if you ain't particular movies
you want to see us talk about and see
our real views on just go ahead and
leave in the comments below we'll try
I'm not too cute or yeah yeah not much
to talk about with that one boring
that's it end of the review so we will
see you next time take care